he is one of the remaining few at
98 walter nixon still lives in the same
house he grew up in
in the 1920s that's the africa star
italian star when walter left his
village in suffolk he had no idea
he would help liberate italy fighting
the germans on anzio beach
in 1944 and as a proud england football
fan
he can't stand anti-german sentiments
the kind of thing that was so evident in
euro 96
and still now a small minority of
england fans
will sing songs about german bombers
i'm disappointed really and people when
they they
heart back that was some eight years ago
and uh um time marches on
and we've got to put all that behind us
now and
can't live with the past you've got to
look for the future
it often seems to go to penalties with
germany
i do like the the uh when won't
finish up with as penalties because
it keeps you on the edge of the chair
this week marks
25 years since gareth southgate's own
penalty nightmare against the germans
in the semi-final of euro 96 a moment
he's used to help motivate the team that
he now leads
this time gareth southgate has a
well-rehearsed method
for the madness of penalties even
practicing the walk up to the penalty
spot
as well as the kicks themselves
many of the squad weren't even born in
1996 let alone 1990
for the germans it's beating the
italians or the dutch
that really matters england germany
games have been
often dramatic often you know historic
but often also
quite positive for us so you don't have
that kind of same sense of
of dread and of of maybe envy or hate
that you would get
against the team that beats you just a
lot more regularly
the england players know they have to
step up their performance
lose and they are out but win and the
juggernaut of expectation
starts to really roll tom parmenter
sky news